[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soirée d'hier soir exactement pépito
savard sa vraie histoire toujours dit à
dispagne voici son nom marseille
toujours
donc je glisse sa pépite aussi mais on
peut peters dans le magnéto ces symboles
en vidéo des années 80 par pitau
s'égrènent au début mais ça marche et
moi alors donc là c'est le première
pépite oh ouais une pépite je crois que
c'est maxime gainey c'est ça avec kelly
bon rappeur bon val-d'or de assez
regardé discuter en vue que se
passe-t-il alors un peu dur à vivre
tout comme
un compte des barrages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est quoi 2e 2e c'est encore
monsieur la regarde et maxime galy
kishin kelly pendant la soirée
[Musique]
au final comment ça se passe entre nous
qu'il faut pas se prononcer il faut pas
se prendre le chou pour pas se prendre
la tête
voilà ne pas faire de plan sur la comète
et avancer by step direct par un jeu qui
nous attend comme ça jean michel nous
fera des sourires enfin tu veux juste
rendre jalouse en mission ou alternatifs
parce honnête j'ai envie de aussi de
rendre jeudi matin michel
les deux font la paire et quand même
dans mes shows yves à pécho state drive
by step by step
quelle ironie vaste buyster exactement
cinéma il a toujours intéressé
ouais aller derrière petit en une
semaine et peut-être des petites pépites
c'est sur vous je crois que c'est sur ma
de cette nature de leurs modestes dans
la soirée au côté je connais de profiter
de tous ces gens que j'aime et qui
m'aiment
ça me fait très plaisir j'aimerais bien
aussi que de temps en temps je les
pousse un peu que vous avez aussi
demandé des photos âge il goûta aux gens
qui vivent pas aux gens qui fonctionnent
mieux c'est vexant mais jésus après
voulait supprimer c'est pas grave mais
c'est aussi ça faire plaisir c'est aux
intermédiaires on est des photos à des
gens dont on se fout
[Applaudissements]